The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I wanted
to give a lecture,
because as I told you in
presentations, I love feedback.
In fact, I love
it so much, that I
think the examples
we're going to do,
we can do analytically
are not maybe
sufficiently compelling for you
to believe how exciting control
can be.
So let me just start by giving
a few minutes of a research
result we had a few years ago.
That's why you've got color
images-- everybody noticed
the color images on the slides.
I brought this robot in
to the first recitation
of [INAUDIBLE].
It's a big 2 meter wing span
ornithopter, and in my case,
we've been trying to design
control systems to make
airplanes move more like birds.
Here's one example of that.
One thing birds do that
planes don't do very well
is land on a perch.
So we asked the question,
can we take a simple airplane
with fixed wings,
no flapping allowed,
and make it land on a perch--
UAV stands for unmanned
aerial vehicle--
land on a perch like a bird.
The story I want to tell you
is that with feedback design,
you can.
Here's why it's
interesting and hard.
The reason airplanes
don't land on a perch
is because, when your wing
is at a low angle, which
a plane normally is
when it's flying,
the air flow around the wing
is relatively easy to model.
It's easy to write a block
diagram description of.
But if you go to moderate
angles, that's still true.
The air stays attached to
the wings and everything--
[INAUDIBLE]
At a low angle, the air is
still attached to the wing,
and so we have very good models
of the airflow around here,
and the lift and drag
forces that you get when
you're flying in these regimes.
But if you go up too far, like
this, then everything changes.
So you think, the air can't
quite stay around the wing.
You get separation.
You get big vortices
pulling off the back.
It's very nonlinear,
very unsteady.
Very complicated flight regime.
And as such, our best
aircrafts to date
mostly stay down in this regime
where we have good models
and we can design conventional
control systems for.
But birds don't do that at all.
So birds are, often, when
they're landing on a perch,
they're up even far beyond this.
Maybe even 90 degrees.
"Angle of attack", it's called.
They're way into this
deep stall regime--
that's called stalling your
wings when that happens.
And it seems like they're doing
a lot better landing on a perch
because we don't see
our airplanes do it.
But you can actually
try to quantify that.
So if you want to compare
the performance of a bird
landing versus a plane landing,
the first thing you have to do
is you have to take out the
differences in mass and wing
area and all these things.
But you can do that.
And a fair comparison
is the distance
averaged drag coefficient,
which is just a way
to scale out the effects
that you'd expect from having
a bigger wing or a bigger mass.
You can plot this
drag coefficient
for a few different vehicles.
This is a standard
runway landing of a 747,
would get the drag
coefficient, just
so you have some
calibration, of about a 0.16.
The X-31 was a super
maneuverable research vehicle.
It was designed to do super
short runway landings,
and it got a drag coefficient
during those landings
of about 0.3.
There's a few other
projects out there
about trying to make
perching planes that
were getting similar numbers.
But then we went out
and looked at nature.
I have some
collaborators at Harvard
that work with real birds.
It turns out-- I
wanted him to tell me
the numbers from some
really elite bird,
like at least a hawk
or something like this.
But they work on pigeons.
So that was the only number
we could get, was a pigeon.
They actually
convinced me by the end
that pigeons are really good.
The way they can sort of
dive through the fence
and get your lunch
by the food trucks?
I mean, that's actually--
they're seriously skilled birds.
We even had-- one
of the fun things
about doing this kind of
research is you get visitors.
We had will.i.am from the Black
Eyed Peas come to the lab.
And he said-- after
we told him the story,
he said pigeons
are ghetto birds.
They got mad stop.
That sort of summarizes it.
You already know the answer.
But if you look at
the drag coefficient
that a bird gets when it's
landing, they get a 10.
So they're doing
orders of magnitude
better than our best planes
in terms of stopping.
If you just want
to be fun about it,
you could say, what
would it take for a 747
to get a 10 to
impress will.i.am.
And it turns out
that 747 would have
to go-- they fly at about 450
miles an hour cruise speed.
It would have to
stop in 40 meters
to do what a bird's doing.
The wings would
probably pop off.
There's problems with that.
But the dynamics are
impressive, of the birds.
And what's more, when
they're doing that,
they're getting
incredible accuracy.
This is one of my favorite
videos of a perching owl.
If you watch really closely,
you can see the airflow
get complicated on his wings.
You can see his leading edge
feathers start to flip over.
Boom.
The way you do that is you
put food by the camera.
We tried to build
these simple planes
and ask if could they do
what the owls are doing,
what the pigeons are doing.
Very simple planes.
We did them in an
indoor environment.
We made it so it was
basically a boring plane,
but it can do very interesting
things in pitch, up and down.
Then we spent some time trying
to build a dynamical systems
representation of the plane.
And how do you do that?
Well, you shoot the
plane a bunch of times
into a fishing net.
And you collect a bunch of data.
And like we talked
about in recitation,
you can potentially
get from that data
a model of the dynamics.
And turns out, we had to
do a nonlinear dynamical
model for the
vehicle, but we could
do a linear actuator model
plus delays and everything.
We built a pretty good model of
the plane, which is sort of--
for an aerodynamics
crowd, this would
tell you that this is
a surprisingly good fit
to the lift and drag forces over
a very large range of angles.
Then we had a 6003
problem, basically.
The nonlinear terms make
it a little different.
And what we did
as a group was we
innovated a way to design
a feedback controller that
could make this thing
very accurate during very
high performance maneuvers.
And a long story short, we
can now shoot an airplane
into a motion capture arena.
This is slowed down
about 11 times.
It's this airplane right here.
And it goes into
a very deep stall.
And we can land with an
accuracy, enough accuracy
to land on a perch.
It turns out if you can build a
good enough control system that
can handle the complexity
of the dynamics,
then you can make
these things happen.
This is just-- to convince
you that the dynamics
are complicated, this is
the flow visualization.
We built a wind tunnel releasing
smoke from the leading edge
and took a picture
of it to show you how
complicated the dynamics were.
So control is potentially
an incredibly powerful idea.
You can make-- we try to make
robots that run like ostriches.
We try to make all
kinds of things happen.
You could imagine
improving wind energy.
all kinds of things
where control is an
integral part of it.
The feedback in there
was absolutely essential.
If I took the same plane and
thought about the model a lot
and then designed a controller,
just a set of commands
to the elevator, to try to
make it land on the perch,
it misses the perch
every single time.
And with feedback,
we can hit-- it's
only with feedback
that we can hit
the perch every single time.
And there's a reason for that.
You guys probably heard
the idea that fighter jets
are unstable without the
control system, right?
Fighter jets are-- a lot
of times, the systems that
have peak
maneuverability, that's
often at odds with stability.
In fact, when you try to make
a very high performance fighter
jet, and you want to be
able to turn, you actually--
if the control system is off,
this thing should be unstable.
It's not a complete pathology,
but that's pretty true,
because what you want, you
can elicit a very fast turn
if you basically let
the system go unstable.
Then you can let the unstable
dynamics of the system
make a very rapid turn.
In fact, it's common to build
a system that is unstable,
and it's only stable when
there's feedback in the loop
so that you can have very
high maneuverability when
you need it.
You've already done feedback
if you took 601, right?
So what I want to do today is--
I taught 601 when some
of you were in there.
I want to go through the example
that you already worked through
in the 601 lab for those
of you that took it.
I think it's sufficiently
complete here
if you didn't take it.
But we want to use that--
I'm going to use that
as an example to build
on what you already know and
to show us with the new tools
how far you can get in thinking
about what that robot did
for you last year.
Do you remember this example of
the little pioneer robot that
had to go to the
wall, the foam wall,
using the noisy sonar sensor?
And we wanted to get a desired
distance from the wall?
And by the end, you guys
were moving the board around
and it was trying
to track the wall?
In that exercise,
in the 601 lab,
you guys tried a bunch
of different gains.
For some gains, we saw responses
that sort of looked like this.
If you gave a desired
distance to a wall,
it would go up to
that desired distance.
For other gains, you
saw some oscillation.
You saw some big
oscillations if you tried
all the gains we recommended.
Now you guys have a
deep understanding
of what kind of things can
cause that type of response.
The way we told you to
think about it in 601
is actually the
way that we often
think about control systems.
Typically, we have something
called the plant, which
describes the dynamics
of the robot or the thing
we're trying to care about.
You guys know why it's
called the plant often?
What would be the history
of calling it "plant"?
It's a weird name for it, right?
Actually, some of this stuff
grew up in the chemical
industry, in chemical plants.
Is that what you said?
No?
It's actually-- it has a
history in chemical plants.
But now everybody calls
their robot plants.
The plant is the dynamics
of our robot, for instance.
You've got some output of that.
In this case, it's the
position to the wall.
A sensor that reads it.
It may have its own dynamics.
And your goal is to take some
reference command, a position
you want to go to,
let's say, compare it
with what the sensor is saying
and build a controller that
takes that error and makes the
robot or control system do what
you want it to do.
In this example, the
one you studied in 601,
the plant was a
very simple model
of the dynamics of the robot.
It was just a first-order model.
We said that the
output, the distance
from the wall, the distance in
front of the wall, at time n
was just the distance in
front of the wall time minus--
because, you remember
the frustration
of the flipped sign, too?
But I kept it consistent here.
So it's T times
the velocity, just
happens that since the
velocity is going this way
and the distance
is getting smaller,
you get a minus T.
This looks almost
like the first-order
approximation of a CT system,
right?
So that's the dynamics
of the vehicle.
The sensor, we're going
to assume for now,
is just perfect, that
it just immediately
tells me the
distance to the wall
and gives the perfect feedback.
And then we designed
a controller, which
just takes the error, the
difference between the desired
position and the
actual position,
multiplies it by a
constant K and comes
up with a velocity command
that goes to the motors.
You can visualize that as
a block diagram, of course.
You get that this
plant model here--
it's got a minus one here
and a minus one here,
so that's equivalent having
a delay in the forward path.
And then it's got feedback,
because the previous signal
was directly put
around to the feedback.
So this part here is
the model of the plant.
Then we put the
T in, with a gain
here, so I guess this
part here is the plant.
Here's our simple controller
and our sensor is perfect.
So that's our block diagram.
We've just turned our
robot into a block diagram.
And we know everything about
how to analyze those things.
You can use the
operator notation.
You could think of it as
a system function, too.
This guy here you know is--
you guys can do this in
your sleep now, almost?
But if I just take
that by itself,
what does that come out to?
It's a plus here.
This is x and y.
So I get y is R x plus y.
Or y over x is R
over 1 minus R. Then
I multiply that by
K and a negative t.
And then I do the
exact same computation
again to get this loop around.
And this is our input
output system function.
Simplify it a little
bit, I get this.
Simplify it a little bit
more to identify the pole,
and you can see that the pole
now looks like 1 plus KT.
T represents the time
step between updates,
K is our feedback gain.
Now, we can start
thinking about what
happens if we choose
different-- let's just
lump K and T together,
because the K you choose
is going to be intimately
connected to time.
In this system, there's no
point in separating them.
So we just talk
about KT as a system.
If we chose KT--
KT is almost always
going to be negative.
You want negative
feedback, in general,
for making things stable.
If we choose KT equals 0.5,
then with that system function,
there's a delay in
the forward path,
so it's going to
be offset by one
and then it's just got the
simple single pole response.
The unit step response
similarly looks like this.
So the question
is, what determines
the speed of that response?
Here you go.
I have to get you to
talk to your neighbor
the way Denny
always seems to get
you to talk to your neighbor.
Take a minute.
Figure out which of these
or none of them do you think
would give you the best response
for this simple block diagram
system.
Talk out loud to your neighbor.
OK.
Show of fingers, what
do you think it is?
OK.
A lot of right answers.
Let's just do it real quick.
The fastest possible
convergence is
going to be at the pole zero.
Pole zero, what's it
going to look like?
It's going to give you--
the best you can do
if you zero this out,
you get the impulse response.
The unit sample
response would just
be R. You're going to have a
delay of 1, that's inevitable.
You get one non-zero entry and
then zeroes everywhere else.
In discrete time
systems, you can actually
kill things in a single step.
You can set a pole at 0 that's
the fastest possible response.
But if you think about
the different responses
for different values of K, you
can use the pole zero diagrams
to pretty much
understand everything
there is to know about it.
For KT less than 0 to
negative 1-- like I said,
we want to think about
negative feedback--
that's going to take us from
out here on the unit circle back
towards the origin.
If I keep making
KT more negative,
it's going to go out here.
If I make KT too
negative, bad things
are going to happen again.
The poles are going to go
outside the unit circle
and will actually
have alternating
diverging responses.
The answer is negative 1.
Negative 1 puts
you at a pole of 0.
Here's to think
about it physically.
If I choose K correctly,
since KT was negative 1,
that means K's going
to be negative 10.
That's going to be commanding
exactly the right speed so
that the robot, after the one
tenth of a second, let's say,
it gets you exactly
to the right position.
Unit sample response in
this case would be saying,
the robot's at zero,
I want it to be at 1,
and then I want it
to be back at zero.
The command is going 0, 1, 0.
And the robot is going to be
almost doing exactly that.
It's going to go from 0
to 1 in a single step.
And then back to 0
in a single step.
It's just going to
be delayed by one.
So you give it a command saying,
go here, go here, go back.
And it's going to do exactly
the right thing-- boom, boom,
except for one step delayed,
because you can't get rid
of that R.
So if I plot it-- let
me draw a stem diagram,
but coming down in time so that
I can line up with the axes
up here.
If I start with an
initial position here,
and I command it to go to
the desired front position,
it's going to go boom right
to that front position
with one unit of delay.
And then it's going to stay
there for the rest of the time.
It would be a unit
step response.
But that's not what we got
to see on the robots in 601,
right?
The real robot didn't
work like that.
And the way we made the robot
model more realistic was we
said, OK, but your
sensor's got some delay.
And actually, if you
knew what was going on
behind those 601 robots, it's
actually had a lot of delay.
There's Python running
serial interfaces
to over the serial link to
the fairly old controller
in the pioneer robot.
So the delay is real.
There's a delay of about 1/10
of a second in the sensor.
If I take that exact same
controller, exact same gain
that I already did, now put
it in this new system that
has an extra delay,
then what happens?
I get a velocity of 10
after one step, looks good.
But then, uh-oh,
there was some delay
in the sensor I didn't
realize was here,
so I'm still going to take
corrective action trying
to get me there.
It's going to move me
all the way to the wall,
smash into the
wall, and then it's
going to realize it was zero.
It's going to-- there's
some delay in seeing that.
It's going to move me back.
And you're going to
get oscillations.
You can see that now by just
adding the model to our block
diagram.
If we put the delay now
in the feedback path,
otherwise, keep the block
diagram exactly the same.
Now, you can write
the system function.
What's the resulting
system function
given that this thing
is in the feedback path?
Go ahead and put your fingers
up when you think you've got it.
All right.
Fantastic.
Just like I did here,
you can just quickly
replace the accumulator there
with the equivalent block
diagram.
Do the loop again.
It's going to be exactly
what we did before,
but it's got a new R
in the feedback path.
Giving us the R-squared here,
just on the feedback path.
It's exactly the same
otherwise except for that R,
and that simplifies out to this.
So the answer was 4.
That's just operator
notation, polynomial algebra.
If we want to find the
poles of that system,
we can just go ahead and
factor the quadratic form
in the denominator.
The roots of the
denominator look something
like this, which is a
little ugly to think about.
But we can think it through.
For general KT-- when KT's
small, KT's about zero,
then I'll go ahead and simplify
that a little bit to say,
KT could sneak inside the--
KT and KT-squared
aren't so different.
We're going to sneak
it inside here.
And then you can see that the
poles end up at-- around K
equal to zero you get
a pole at the origin.
But you also get a pole
up by the unit circle.
Around 1 and around 0.
Remember, when you've got
multiple poles in the system,
the total response is
going to be dominated
by whatever is the slower pole.
The total system
response is going
to be dominated by
the slower pole.
In this case, the slower pole's
the one closer to the unit
circle.
What about if KT
equals negative 0.25?
We can pop that in and solve it.
Exactly-- math works out nicely.
We get poles at a half,
two poles at a half.
And in fact, there's a smooth
transition between-- if you
look at the numbers between KT
equals zero and KT equals 0.25,
you'll see as you
vary that gain,
the poles move together
along the real axis
until they come
together at a half.
So here, you've got a purely
real response dominated
by these poles at a half.
System's stable.
If you keep changing K though,
the poles came together
and then they split off
and start going this way.
And in fact, if you look
at negative 1, which
is the one that was
the best response,
it put a pole exactly at 0,
for the system with no delay.
If you put it at the
system with delay,
they land exactly
on the unit circle.
Right there.
Complex poles on
the unit circle.
You're going to get
a stable oscillation.
Which is exactly
what we saw there.
Just a quick-- you know this
like the back of your hand now,
but what's the period
of that oscillation?
You've got two poles on the
unit circle right there.
What's the period
of oscillation?
Put your fingers up
when you think you know.
Yep.
Good.
Most people got it.
This thing was a half, so it's
1/2 square root of 3 over 2.
So that thing had
to be at pi over 3.
It's actually the
same pole that I was
using in recitation yesterday.
So if you have a
pole at pi over 3,
it makes it around in six steps.
The period of the
oscillation is six.
This is generally
true, that if you
put a controlled
gain, a feedback gain,
into the closed loop dynamics,
then even a simple gain
can allow you to really shift
around the poles of the system.
And since we know the response
of the system, the zeros
matter, but for convergence,
for the rate of convergence,
it's the biggest
pole that dominates.
It's very nice to understand
how those poles move with K.
If you change the
system, the way
they move with K is different.
And you can just change
K to tune the response
to be what you want, from
KT equals 0 to infinity,
the poles go towards
here and then off in both
directions, actually,
to infinity.
So, KT equals negative 1 was
the fastest possible response
for the system without
any delay in the sensor.
What's the fastest possible
response for this one?
Oscillations are allowed.
I just want the fastest
possible response.
Yeah.
Looks good.
So where do I want the poles
to be for the fastest possible
response?
These poles are still
stable and oscillations are
fine, but the absolute--
the magnitude of
those poles is larger
when they're out
here in the complex.
When I'm down here,
I have got a pole
over by one, that's
going to dominate.
So the best I can do is if
I put the poles at a half.
That gives us the largest
pole, the smallest
possible magnitude.
And that happened if the poles--
the double poles at a half
happened when KT
was negative 0.25.
Most of you said,
the answer is 2.
In general, delay
is a bad thing.
In DT systems, we have good
representations of delay.
It's even worse in
continuous time.
Delay is a bad thing.
It tends to make control
systems not work as well.
If you just took the ideal
sensor, we had a K equals 1,
we had a response that started
here, we could put it anywhere
we wanted along the real axis.
As far negative as
we wanted, of course,
what we chose was to put
it right at the origin.
But as soon as we just added
that one piece of delay,
the things we could do
with proportional feedback
changed completely,
and ultimately,
got worse because I have
two poles now, first of all,
and I can't simultaneously
get both of those poles
to go to zero.
In fact, as I change them,
they go off into complex.
The fact that it's
complex isn't bad.
But the fact that there's two of
them, and the best I can do now
is get to a half, which is a
much slower response, the best
possible response.
If I added even more delay,
things get even worse.
If I had two units
of delay and I
went through the same
exercise, what you'd see
is that the poles would
start in the same place.
They'd come together
and go there,
and there's another
pole that goes off.
Just because there are
three poles in that system.
Two poles come together
and split off this way.
And this one goes off this way.
And the place you
probably want, depending
on how fast this one
splits off, but the place
you probably want to put it is
when the two poles are together
right there.
That's going to give you
the fastest response.
But that fastest response is
still slower than what we had--
it's a bigger
number than a half.
It's 0.682.
It's going to be a
worse response than when
I had a delay of one,
which is intuitive.
That's a quick reminder
of something you already
did in 601, of using feedback
and the tools we've already
got, which is poles and zeros
and everything, to understand
how to design feedback gains.
We're going to get more into it
in the next couple of lectures.
But let me just convince
you that this stuff is real.
And I showed this
diagram once in 601,
but it probably means
even more to you now.
This is an F-14.
It's one of the best
modern engineering control
systems ever built. It
was built for this F-14.
They got more research money
and modeling this vehicle,
designing ultimate gains for it.
It's such a success story
that you can actually,
if you're in MATLAB, you
can open up the F-14 demo
and see what a flight control
system for an F-14 looks like.
MATLAB-- I don't know if
you've played with Simulink--
MATLAB has a language called
Simulink, a graphical language
that allows you to
draw the block diagrams
and simulate them and even
design controllers for them.
And it turns out you
can make a block diagram
description of an F-14 using
only tools from 601 and 6003.
You can see all the
same adders and gains,
transfer functions, system
functions like this.
The only essential difference
is that in some of the diagrams,
you see multiple
inputs coming in.
In this class, we've
restricted ourselves
so far to thinking about single
input, single output systems,
which keeps everything clean.
All the intuition scales
to multiple inputs
and multiple outputs.
But that's sort of the only
big addition of complexity
when you go to this model
from what we've done before.
If you zoom in onto the
controller here, you can--
these block diagrams
in this language
allow you to abstract away
a bunch of hidden things
with a single transfer function.
If I zoom in, then you can
see things you recognize.
It's got a low-pass
filter, which
is just a system with
a pole at negative 1,
exactly what we did in
recitation the other day.
This is what people--
this is what MATLAB
uses on an F-14.
I guess it might not be
what the military uses.
But it's modeled after what
the unclassified documents say
is happening on an F-14.
Everything here, you
understand, right?
A proportional
controller in the end.
One difference in
F-14s is that--
and in general for these
more complicated systems--
they'll design slightly
different controllers
given the situation.
So if you have an altimeter
on there and pressure sensors,
an inclinometer will tell
you the angle of the plane--
given those sensors,
they'll pick a different K
for a proportional
controller out
of a pot of a library
of controllers
they've already designed.
So it's called gain
scheduled control.
But the analysis
and design of each K
is a linear systems
design and analysis.
This is super powerful stuff.
I think-- signal
processing is good, too,
but control is where it's at.
I guess I went a
little fast, but that's
your introduction to feedback.
We'll do DT and CT feedback in
the next couple of lectures.
And if anybody hasn't
picked up their exams,
we have them over here.
And we'll see you in
recitation tomorrow.